Stanley Blades,
sprinted up onto the stage. Splash.
Okay, that's a little bit more crazy,
actually. Splash.
Splash. Splash.
Mug. You mug. This guy is like so Will
Lyman. If YouTube is going to kick off,
people like we've seen them kick off,
why is this tolerated?
I'm hearing that Konstantin Kisin
was almost
by these didgeridoos
recently at his
debate in London.
I'm hearing terrible things, guys. I'm
hearing
horrible news. I know that sounds crazy.
That sounds crazy.
So, we're going to take a look. And
we've got just the right person to tell
us about it. First of all, actually,
let's
Hopefully, everyone knows who Konstantin
Kisin and Destiny are. So, yeah,
Konstantin, obviously, you know, he's
sort of the main guy on Trigger
He's really the main guy on
Triggerometry.
Um and he debated Destiny in London
about immigration, I believe. Now, I
don't I didn't cover that because I
would probably agree with Destiny.
And I think he's a disgusting lowlife.
So, I just avoid covering anything where
I'm going to support him. Uh now, this
is a funny element to it, however.
Warren Smith has posted a video today.
Um you'll see it see it here called How
Close Konstantin Kisin Came to Being
Assassinated
during his debate with Destiny.
So, that sounds pretty crazy, guys. That
sounds pretty crazy. Konstantin Kisin
was close to being assassinated
during his debate with Destiny. Now,
I've said a lot of Warren Smith before.
Warren Smith is another guy that we we
love here.
He's a pretentious uh
fake deep faux deep
suit hack
worthless idiot uh MAGA grifter
who got popular for doing like these
videos where he was like a high school
teacher or something.
And he'd do these like videos asking
students about like
J.K. Rowling and
gender neutral bathrooms and whatever
the
And one of them got shared on Twitter by
Elon Musk and he got a huge surge in
popularity and got and took off from
there. And he's made this video here.
And so I look at this video and I go
Well, I'm expecting this video to be him
not really presenting anything.
Just sort of going like
Yeah, so and he does this how he talks.
I think that
temperature in America has just gotten
really extreme. And act as like Destiny
with their audience.
But he would just like talk about how
Destiny calls for violence or something.
Now, that's not the case.
That's not the case. He's actually
talking about a
attendant an attendant an audience
member
at the debate
who apparently spoke about what he
wanted to do to Konstantin Kisin on live
stream.
So, let's take a look and see. Is this a
DG Gia talking about
Konstantin Kisin and is Destiny
responsible? Let's take a look, guys.
This is huge. And from
>> Also, I have to go to AFK to get food in
like 2 minutes. Ollie Kirk killing. This
guy was sitting here a few feet away
from Konstantin Kisin during his debate
with Destiny. When you hear what he has
to say, it is scary to think how this
could have gone. I was like [__]
locked onto his eyes and he kept like
glancing down at me and then like
breaking eye contact cuz I I [__]
hate the guy. I was just like I wanted
to kill him. I stumbled upon this stream
when I was just trying to research and
understand the opposing view and I was
shocked by
>> No, what an idiot.
So, immediately, that's my first
instinct on that is not that he he's
going to kill. It's just that he is just
expressing hatred in a comedic way.
I often like to talk like this myself.
So I can see it.
Um
He's just expressing hatred in a comedic
way. I don't think it So far, he's
actually saying he was going to do
anything.
However, this is incredibly [__]
stupid to do on a live stream, it must
be said, especially when you're actually
there. I use some of the things this guy
was saying. Keep in mind, this guy was
sitting in Konstantin's eyeline. And I
think he got distracted by that and
didn't pay attention to a single thing.
What do you think of that? Yes, it is
just talk, but there is something more
disturbing beneath the surface here.
Right. He's openly talking about wanting
to assassinate Konstantin. This could
have gone Well,
I can imagine where he gets it from. Cuz
I know it's, you know,
I've seen some
some people going around online being
like, "How is Destiny responsible for
this? I mean, Destiny wouldn't approve
of this."
>> to preface this video by stating that I
was the only one that reached out to
every about you saying like, "Hey, I
wish this person Has this person been
doxxed yet?"
Yeah, I um for Anna, that's [__]
For Justin and Kleiman, I'd kill him if
I could. I'd choke the [__] house
into it. Bro, I swear to god, if I quit
streaming, I'm going to [__] go on an
assassination mission, [laughter] okay?
I'm going to [__] kill you guys one
at a time, okay?
>> why this video Why does it Why does this
misguided wayward young man think it's
okay to get on live stream
and start talking about murdering people
that he doesn't like from the internet?
Why does he Why does he think it's Why
does he think it's so cool to get on and
do that? I wonder. I wonder who um
who made him think that was uh that was
smart.
You get away with that in the UK.
I wonder who made him think that was a
good idea.
gone very differently. Uh he even has a
box cutter or X-ACTO knife. Josh should
have done
Stanley blade, just [__] sprinted up
onto the stage, slash Konstantin in the
[__] jugular. But he wants to kill
him. Okay, that's a little bit more
crazy, actually. That's a little bit
worse.
That's worse than the first two. The
first two where he's just aiming the
guns and saying like, "Oh,
you know, I hate him so much."
That was a little bit like, you know,
whatever.
You know, I I could totally see myself
saying that.
But actually saying like, "I should have
run up on the like
That's a different thing. That's a
little bit different. You can see the
chat. They're all thinking the same
thing, it seems. No one seems to be
bothered by this because it has become
so commonplace. He knows he can do this.
YouTube's not going to do anything.
Done. So, a prison forever on the one
hand,
prison forever on the one hand,
and then I and then I should have gone
then I should have gone woke jihad.
Woke jihad.
I should have No, I should have gone for
the white race or something, I don't
know.
You could say, "Okay, well, he just
worded that poorly. It's just an
expression." But he takes this much
further. Then he gets into, "Based on
what happened to Charlie Kirk, this is
what I have learned when it comes to how
to kill conservatives."
Now, I feel like
my genuine psychopath thought that I've
learned from the Charlie Kirk killing
is
if you are Wow, you can't tell this
guy's a destiny viewer, can you?
all going to
assassinate a political target,
then try to reduce the gore as much as
possible so people can't sympathize
with the bastard
who's getting it.
So, you you'd have to go up with like a
cape and like a cover them in a cape and
do it cleanly under there, you know?
Like a like a an abattoir.
So, he's literally openly talking about
assassinating political targets here.
So, the question is
>> That's That's what he's doing. That's
what I wanted to understand. That's why
I wrote We can always rely on Warren,
can't we? Warren's always on the money,
bro. Warren's always on the money.
He's talking about
assassinating political enemies.
That is what was happening in the last
three clips you played, Warren. Yes,
we're 3 minutes into the video now. take
the time to even look at these streams.
It's all like dog whistling
uh we need to
>> I know it was all Jeremy uh future for
white people. He makes it very clear his
belief is Konstantin is a racist. And
all it is
is
appealing [clears throat]
or dog whistling to the stupidest
voters. Like like You may not like him.
But I'm not talking about this guy. I
mean Warren. You may not like him, but
he's right.
You may not like him.
But he's what he but he's right.
dumbest 10% of people
who happen to be racist as well Shuku fu
racism. But then he talks about the real
problem here is the
weak culture of the UK. We simply don't
have the white people stepping up and
educating themselves in the right kinds
of ways because of culture issues, I
guess, because of the weak white
culture. Wow.
>> He is the very thing
he thinks he is fighting against. His
entire analysis of Konstantin's ideas
are absolutely mischaracterized. He's
not contending with them at all. And
then he uses those ideas as his
justification. Based on these [__]
ideas for me to vote for the green
candidate, you [__] piece of [__]
Konstantin. I [__]
slap
slap slap mug you mug Well, the thing is
This provides us a window into this
mentality, into the psychology of people
like this. It's important to understand.
It's important to see. See, here's the
thing, man.
This guy could have totally used this.
He's just been too [__]
If you got Warren to make this video and
you weren't actually
saying like [__] that's totally deranged
and you could defend it in some way
this would be great promotion.
But instead, Konstantin Kisin has called
We'll get to this. Konstantin Kisin has
reported this guy to the police.
So, this guy may be getting a [__]
knock at the door, to be honest. This
guy may actually get pulled in.
It's the UK. You can't [__] around quite
like you can in America.
So,
Hadn't also at the same time had the
doctrine
>> of this would be much easier to manage
if I got in that stage, grab his [__]
lapels, right? Put him in and [__]
air palm, bang, right over. You know you
know what I'm talking about? I'm talking
about right over my hip. Konstantin's
right over my hip. I've got his [__]
lapels.
I genuinely don't understand it. Even if
you disagree with Konstantin, how could
what he's saying upset you this much?
>> This guy is so willy mac coded. Do you
know what I mean? This guy is like so
willy mac coded.
understand it. Even if you disagree with
Konstantin, how could what he's saying
upset you this much? I just feel You're
right.
>> He's like willy mac coded. wasn't like
inbred as [__]
Do you know what I mean? disagree with
Konstantin, how could what he's saying
upset you this much? I just feel You're
right. You're right. You're right. By
the lapels, [__] whoosh.
Right, I'm talking bang, and his whole
body just goes
whoosh into the [__] wood. That's
what I'm saying.
And people will claim this guy doesn't
have a massive reputation. Okay, but we
see these same ideas reflected at a
higher level. Literally just yesterday,
I stumbled on a stream where Destiny's
head moderator is trying to talk to
Destiny because he is concerned because
he has seen too many calls for violence
in their Discord server, and he's
beginning to worry that people aren't
actually joking. Yesterday, I think
Destiny referred to it as like kind of
school shooter vibes going on as far as
how people are talking in a way that
makes people think that like not just
radical and like
I'm I'm so tired of people saying like,
"Well, Trump
>> Well, wait till Warren finds out that
after they had the campaigning event
that they had to do a whole big stream
discussing how the community had issues
talking to women and leaving women alone
when they're trying to do things other
than talk to men.
Wait till Warren finds out.
>> [laughter]
>> It radicalizes me. You should be radical
under Trump. I'm talking about radical
as in like
going to cause violence in a way that
isn't what everybody thinks it is kind
of way. And I know like your argument is
like, "Well, people like Trump and
>> Yeah, dude. Honestly,
Destiny did not realize how good he had
it with 4thought.
4thought was like, you know, as much as
he was a total power tripping,
you know, [__]
I I There are like three different words
that came into my head to say that and I
can't say any of them.
But, you know,
you know.
Drizzy B B L 4thought B B L 4thought.
Um at least he he could kind of interact
online. That was one of them.
At least he could kind of interact
online, you know?
He could kind of do it. He could throw
jokes out.
You know, he could kind of fit in with
the DGG crowd. This guy's like a total
sped. This guy's like a total [__]
[__]
things like that like they can say this
stuff openly and like I I completely
understand that argument. My my argument
>> left cuz he got like brigaded out. He
got like brigaded out by Dan, right?
is that people aren't taking this
serious and if they are taking it
serious and they are meaning the words
that they're saying and they're not
joking that that is the problem. Okay.
Everyone's joking though.
But, everybody's not joking though.
My my concern is that we are vastly
approaching the
like point of no return in our own
rhetoric within the community and I
think that it is being furthered by us
not addressing it.
>> I'm forced to ask myself, how is I hate
Warren's videos so much.
The [__] music comes in. The music
comes in. I hate these videos, bro.
being furthered by us not addressing it.
>> I'm forced to ask myself, how is this If
YouTube is going to kick off people like
we've seen them kick off, why is this
tolerated?
Thank you. Wait, Warren calling for
Destiny's ban?
Or just this guy?
Yeah, he can't suggest I mean, we
introduce new things, so I don't know
what I don't know what the monoculture
is. I hear I People are going to claim,
"Yeah, but this guy's not famous. He
isn't He's not No one really knows who
he is, that's why." But how is that even
relevant?
And multiculturalism
>> massive under which of instead of
creating a monoculture into which people
are encouraged to buy in and integrate,
they've instead created a a society in
which people are encouraged to see
themselves as members of an individual
community. He fails to see that he is
becoming He is the very thing he thinks
his opponents are.
>> I don't know. That's what he died But
this is what I hate about these people
is like they make a career,
right?
They make a career out of violent and
aggressive politics and riling it up and
stoking it up.
So therefore, we should
take them out because they're riling
things up. They're too full of hatred.
>> Like you It's just like you're um not
only do you make your own life hard when
you do [__] like this.
You're letting the team down. Let's be
serious. You're letting the team down.
For better or worse, you know, I I
actually [__] hate, you know, DDG and
Destiny and all these [__] losers and
this guy seems like a total queer.
But uh unfortunately,
we are in basically
the exact same strain of politics.
Um I probably agree on like 95% of
things.
So
they're kind of on the team in a way.
They're going to be viewed as on the
team by other people.
And
you make everyone even as far as
lefties, right? Even as far as like
lefties, they're going to be on the same
team to righties.
Um
and
it's just like you make it look so bad.
You just give
you're like a
you're like the trans person doing the
strip strip show for
all ages. Do you know what I mean?
You're the trans person doing the strip
show for all ages.
That's what you are.
You need to just not don't give them
that. Just don't give them that. Why are
you giving them that?
So, we should hate them.
And then they're like, "Oh, thank you
for letting me discuss the ideas and
really hear your side of
>> the I still have not read D Pramod's
message cuz I was avoiding reading it.
[__] Oh, so they're ruining your
country, but Constantin can't have
concerns about people ruining his
country. I think that concepts like
England were created
in order for
monarchs to consolidate power in their
kingdoms. wank Uh and [music] if this
continues, it will only get worse. And
this could have gone very differently.
How do people get to the point of what
you're seeing in this video? Well,
[music] it all comes down to the laws of
narrative. There's always going to be
people that wish you harm. You just have
to learn how to spot [music] them. And
if you're interested in these concepts,
I do have a book coming out in August.
I've been working on this for 2 [music]
years. I began writing it when I was
still a high school teacher. It's meant
to be more of a
methodology. The reality is we have
opponents every day. It was meant to be
that kind of book that people
Buy my ebook.